[Music]
European citizens must be at the heart
of an ambitious recovery strategy that's
what MEP say in a resolution on the
future
EU long-term budget and the recovery
plan following the kovat 19 pandemic
members are calling for a global package
of two trillion euros of public and
private investment at its core should be
the recovery fund which would deliver
assistance mostly in the form of grants
Parliament wants the fund to be built
into the --use next seven-year budget
set to start in 2021 the economic reboot
must come on top of and not at the cost
of pre-existing programs for the EU to
meet these expectations without
increasing contributions from member
states Parliament insists on finding new
sources of EU revenue
[Music]
European legislators want the EU economy
to be better equipped to deal with
emergencies like the corona virus
pandemic by creating a new European
health program the recovery fund should
address inequalities and mitigate the
social and economic impacts of the
crisis this means supporting small and
medium businesses consumers workers and
families Parliament has been adamant
that the Green Deal and the European
Digital Agenda be a priority in the next
long-term budget and the recovery
strategy if its demands are not met
Parliament warns it will make use of its
veto powers